hey there you are
thanks for meeting me here well if you'd
held him here instead of that conference
room i would have come to more meetings
i got to tell you leslie establishing
this national park right next to pawnee
is quite an accomplishment this is a
fine piece of land you saved
thank you ron you want to run it
the superintendent of bryce canyon
retired and i convinced the
superintendent of this park to transfer
shuffled a few things around the point
is someone needs to take care of this
place now thought it should be you
i well first of all
i would be working for the federal
government your job would be to walk
around the land alone you'd live in the
same town you've always lived in you'd
work outside you'd talk to bears next
argument well there must be dozens of
people
gunning for this job i wouldn't want you
to ruffle any feathers
am i even qualified well a few people
might be annoyed but they'll get over it
and as far as your qualifications
you're ron swanson stop being a dummy
and accept
when do i start oh today i already
accepted for you i still remember how to
forge your signature
let's go meet your staff
pawnee national park rangers this is ron
swanson
your new superintendent and boss
rangers my name is ronald ulysse swanson
your job and mine is to walk this land
and make sure no one harms it
if you show up on time speak honestly
and treat everyone with fairness we will
get along just fine
though hopefully not too fine as i'm not
looking for any new friends
end of speech well said
thank you leslie you're welcome ron
okay time to go to work
laugh with me buddy just with me
buddy don't let her get the best of me
buddy don't ever let me
start feeling lonely
[Music]
day one i'm in the interior of the vast
pennsylvania wilderness
i've brought with me only the bare
essentials
a knife a roll of duct tape
in case i need to fashion a shelter or
make some sort of water vessel
it's hot today the sun is in the
two-thirds
easterly quadrant which would make it
about
two o'clock in the afternoon really
beating down on me now
i think that i want to get a little more
comfortable
because the sun is depleting my
resources
okay that oh there we go
watch that i don't hit my corroded
artery
here i lied to michael i said that i
would leave him alone but i will not
i will remain close by to provide unseen
moral support
but i will never help him i will let
harm befall him i will even let him die
but i will never let him lose his
dignity
there we go much better now everything
i brought with me can be used
my sport coat here can be fashioned
into a backpack of sorts
i'm going to wear what was once
one of my pant legs
see this is a beautiful piece of
material this can be used for all sorts
of things
some sort of kerchief
to keep my neck nice and comfortable i
am
totally alone right now with only my
thoughts
i love it i'm loving it
i can literally say anything i want no
one
is going to hear me wish i could have
gone with ryan on that cool retreat
janet has plastic boobs i
have hemorrhoids
doesn't even matter michael is a man of
great depth and
passion i don't know what he's searching
for out here
i hope he finds it
lunch
about two more minutes
and take a look at this i tented my
pants
i've made myself a nice pants tent
shelter and this little guy may be
dunder mifflin paper someday
nothing to worry about just using the
scope safety is
on so what's on our schedule mr swanson
we have one activity planned not getting
killed
boys i'm trying to teach you something
about nature and self-reliance
nothing beats hard work and
determination
is this the pawnee goddesses i've got
the puppies you ordered oh
the puppies for the puppy party that
we're having in our cabin those puppies
what is that smell that is the absence
of urine
you got to leave brooklyn to get that no
urine i could get used to this
oh yes and that's just the beginning my
friend just waited you're sitting
fireside sipping on a premium chinese
scotch and smoking a sweet rwandan cigar
okay okay i probably could have done
without the countries of origin but that
sounds great
yeah what else do you have planned oh so
much i'm talking fishing i'm talking
poker
i'm talking frisbee boyle what else am i
talking wildflower picking so we can
make our own cologne nope i was talking
bonfires and s'mores but that's my fault
for throwing to you
this is gonna be fun as hell this is
gonna be the best weekend
ever welcome to stink puddle manor
stink puddle manor
well i don't really go camping ever
jerry so i'm not gonna spend 150
on a tent just gonna sleep on the floor
it's called the ground
when it's outside whatever i know we'll
never be soul mates but
we're friends now get in this boat and
read some boring french poetry
i i've never actually done this before
this is this is a theoretical fantasy
how do you row a boat fishing relaxes me
it's like yoga except i still get to
kill something
and just as you have planted your seed
in the ground
i am going to plant my seed in you
i think you know what you're saying
smells pretty bad doesn't it
uh-huh it's called bull crap and a
client can smell it from a mile away
gotcha okay everyone shut up
and look at me welcome to visions of
nature this room has several paintings
in it some are big some are small
people did them and they are here now i
believe that after this is over they'll
be hung in government buildings why the
government is involved in an art show is
beyond me
i also think it's pointless for a human
to paint scenes of nature
when they could just go outside and
stand in it
anyway please do not misinterpret the
fact that i am talking right now as
genuine interest
in art and attempt to discuss it with me
further
end of speech should you be our manager
i wouldn't let her manage a celery farm
those who can't farm
farm celery fine i'll talk to you
but you got to follow me i got to go
feed the hogs oh my god what are you
going to feed them is it us
corn oh corn maze as there was at the
first thanksgiving
right let's go talk oh this is pungent
out here
so weird how food smells so good but
farms smell so bad
yeah i think that every day it's really
important to me that april loves camping
so i
went ahead and set up the ultimate
campsite
love nest complete with beautiful
starlight we got champagne
also rose petals as you can see they
smell terrific
hey where are you i'm here where are you
we're inside the main entrance near the
sign that says quantity campground
oh i'm in a totally different place
that's why we can't see each other oh my
god andy i don't even want to be here
the air is too fresh it's disgusting i
can't breathe
there's a brook somewhere that won't
stop babbling shut up
sweetheart just hold tight and uh i'll
be there
well april is right here and i
am down here somewhere
[Music]
hello andy you have to save me i'm
camping with people i work with
hello april hello walk around in circles
like i am
help triangulate the phone call
hello hang on i'm gonna try to get to
higher ground
ah wow i found some thorns
you